كانت قضية حقوق المرأة
مصدر قلق كبير في أعقاب استيلاء طالبان
على أفغانستان ،
خشي الكثير من العودة إلى الفترة القمعية
لحكم طالبان في التسعينيات ،
وقد تم بالفعل إعادة فرض بعض القواعد الصارمة على ملابس النساء ، لذا فقد
تم بالفعل إعادة
فرض العشرات من النساء الأفغانيات.  الانتقال إلى
وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي لإظهار
نسختهم من
اللباس الأفغاني التقليدي
والملون للعالم بهار جلالي ، بدأت مؤسسة أول
برنامج لدراسات النوع الاجتماعي في
البلاد الاتجاه على تويتر عندما
شاركت هذه الصورة لنفسها ،
تقول جلالي إنها تريد الاقتباس
تبديد المعلومات المضللة
التي تروجها حركة طالبان
السياسية البريطانية بيمانا أسد كانت
تزور عائلتها في أفغانستان عندما
اجتاحت طالبان كابول
وتمكنت من الخروج من
البلاد في الوقت المناسب ، أعتقد أن هذا
هجوم على الهوية الأفغانية
والثقافة الأفغانية  إنها تحاول
إعادة أفغانستان إلى نسخة أكثر تطرفاً
من الإسلام كانت
تلك النسخة معروضة في الكاب
حيث جلست مئات النساء اللواتي يرتدين
ملابس سوداء من الرأس إلى أخمص القدمين في
قاعة محاضرات جامعية للتعبير
عن دعمهن للحكومة الجديدة
، شارك متحدث باسم طالبان هذا
الفيديو لتجمع في العاصمة
تحدثت فيه هذه المرأة ضد ما يسمى
بالمثل الغربية.
هؤلاء النساء اللائي يميلن إلى الغرب
ويمليهن الغرب لا يمكنهن
تمثيل النساء المسلمات والمتدينات في
أفغانستان ، لكن ملابس النساء ليست
الشيء الوحيد الذي تتم مناقشته ،
حيث قالت طالبان إنه سيظل مسموحًا للنساء
بالدراسة في الجامعات ولكن ليس جنبًا إلى جنب مع
الرجال
في أفغانستان.  في الماضي ، لم يسمح طالبان حتى
للفتيات والنساء بالذهاب إلى المدرسة ،
لكن وزير التعليم يقول إن الحكومة الجديدة
لا تريد
إعادة عقارب الساعة إلى الوراء 20 عامًا ،
لقد بدأنا مؤخرًا في تطبيق
الاقتراح الذي اقترحته الجامعات
فيما يتعلق بالفصل بين الذكور والإناث.
ولا نرى أي تأثير سلبي على
النساء اللاتي يرتدين الزي الإسلامي
التقليدي لسن بالضرورة مناصرات للطالبان ، لكن
قد يكون هذا هو الهدف
في  المجتمع الحر يجب أن يكون للمرأة
خيار ارتداء ما تريد
والتمتع بنفس الحقوق التي يتمتع بها الرجل ، من
الواضح أن أفغانستان لم تعد حرة
للنساء
بيكي أندرسون سي إن إن أبو ظبي